Christians believe that Jesus is God
Christians also believe that Jesus died
on the cross so Christians must believe
that God died but God is eternal and
unchanging and Immortal and all powerful
what sense does it make to say that he
died confused yet not for long because
in this video I'm going to do three
things first I'm going to State what the
Christian position is so that everyone
knows what we're claiming second since
this issue is most frequently brought up
by Muslims as an objection to
Christianity I'm going to help our
Muslim friends understand the Christian
view by drawing attention to an
interesting parallel with Islamic
Theology and finally I'm going to show
why the Christian view is correct and
why the Muslim view most certainly is
not so this discussion is mainly geared
towards Christians and Muslims but
anyone who's watching even you atheists
will soon have a better understanding of
Christianity and Islam in the first
verse of the Book of John we read in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was God so the
word logos in Greek was in the beginning
before anything was created verse three
says that everything was created through
the word the word was with God
indicating that there's some sort of
distinction between God and the word
later to be fully clarified as Father
Son and Holy Spirit and the Word was God
indicating that the word was by nature
in essence God verse 14 goes on to say
that the word became flesh and made his
dwelling among us this is referring of
course to
Jesus so Christians aren't saying that
God as he exists eternally died one day
the Christian claim is that the second
person of the Trinity who is in nature
in essence God and who is with the
father and the Holy Spirit entered into
creation taking on human flesh as Jesus
of Nazareth and that because he took on
a human nature he was able to die as a
human being there's a similar passage in
Philippians 2 in your relationships with
one another have the same mindset as
Christ Jesus who being in very nature
God did not consider equality with God
something to be used to his own
Advantage rather he made himself Nothing
by taking the very nature of a servant
being made in human likeness and being
found in appearance as a man he humbled
himself by becoming obedient to death
even death on a cross therefore God
exalted him to the highest place and
gave him the name that is above every
name that at the name of Jesus every
knee should bow in heaven and on Earth
and under the Earth and every tongue
acknowledge that Jesus Christ is Lord to
the glory of God the
father that's what Christians are
claiming because that's what the Bible
claims but our Muslim friends insist
either that God can't enter into his
creation or that he can but he just
wouldn't they'll even make up rules
about this they'll say that if God
enters creation as Jesus of Nazareth
then he can't be God because anything in
creation is dependent and therefore
Unworthy of worship anything that is in
the creation cannot be God because they
are dependent and anything that's
dependent cannot be deserved of worship
of course there are hadiths about Allah
descending from the highest heaven to
the lowest Heaven the lowest Heaven is
what you see when you look up at the sky
so it's our world if Allah descends to
our world then he definitely enters
creation assuming he ever leaves for
instance jamat ter
446 Allah's messenger said Allah blessed
and exalted is he descends to the
Earth's Heaven every night when the
first third of the night has passed he
says I Am The Sovereign is there any who
calls upon me so that I may respond to
him is there any who asks of me that I
may give him is there any who seeks
forgiveness from me so that I may
forgive him apparently Allah can't hear
prayers from far away he needs to get
really close in order to hear what
people are saying hence he descends to
our world how do our Muslim friends who
tell us that if God enters into creation
he isn't worthy of worship
respond We Believe Allah subhana wa
ta'ala enters into his creation he said
the seven uh the lowest part of Heaven
the way he beit his majesty how that
happens how how it happens I have no
idea how it
happens say what now what we're seeing
is how does he enter it we don't know
what we say is that the way it does it
is the way heits his majesty if you're
starting to think that they make up
rules as they go along while they
simultaneously violate the rules they
make up you're absolutely right but you
can't blame them they're just following
the example of their Prophet who did the
exact same thing so Allah enters into
creation every night to find out what's
going on but there are different time
zones it's always night somewhere which
means that Allah is constantly darting
back and forth ascending and descending
he must spend quite a bit of time in his
creation by the way weren't all the
heavens created by Allah so so when is
he not in his
creation anything that is in the
creation cannot be God because they are
dependent and anything that's dependent
cannot be deserving of worship here our
Muslim friends will say okay yes Allah
enters into creation but it's not like
he's entering into some specific thing
like he does in
Christianity you sure about that in
Surah 27: 7-9 we read remember when
Moses said unto his family verily I
perceive a fire I shall bring you some
news there from or a brand that happily
you may warm yourselves then when he
came to it A call came unto him blessed
is the one in the fire and the one
around it and glory be to God lord of
the worlds oh Moses verily it is I God
the Mighty the
wise who is the one around the the fire
Moses who is the blessed one in the fire
Allah God the Mighty the
wise now if Allah can enter into his
creation enter into a fire and speak out
of a fire why in the name of Common
Sense can't he enter into his creation
enter into a human body and speak out of
a human body what's the new rule that
Muslim dies are going to make up so that
they can once again tell us what God can
and cannot do perhaps our Muslim friends
will reply okay yes God can enter into
his creation but if he does he obviously
can't die because he's God God is
eternal and Immortal something that's
Eternal and Immortal can't die that may
sound reasonable but if Muslims are
correct here they've just destroyed the
Theology of the Quran according to Islam
the Quran is the Eternal speech of Allah
it has no beginning it was not created
it cannot be destroyed watch how easy
this is here's the
Quran I open the Quran and the first
thing I see is a publication date
1997 is this eternal it doesn't seem
Eternal how is it uncreated if it was
public in
1997 can it be destroyed it's made of
paper and glue and ink highly
flammable there are plenty of videos on
YouTube and various other sites of
people destroying the Quran in lots of
different ways people rip it up they
burn it they eat its Pages they feed its
pages to animals they use its pages to
make beautiful origami
sculptures think about this our Muslim
Friends Ask how how can God die as if
this somehow refutes the Christian view
but let me ask how can the Eternal
speech of Allah be ripped up burned
eaten fed to animals and used for
origami the Quran is Allah's Eternal
uncreated unchanging Incorruptible
speech something that's Eternal and
uncreated and unchanging and
Incorruptible isn't the sort of thing
that can be ripped up or burned or eaten
or fed to animals or used for origami
and yet people have ripped this up and
burned it and eaten it and fed it to
animals and used it for
origami how is that
possible the correct response According
to Islamic theology is that this Quran
has two
Natures on the one hand as the Eternal
Word of Allah it has no beginning it was
not created it cannot be
destroyed on the other hand this Quran
is made of paper and glue and ink these
are physical materials this physical
Quran does have a beginning it was
created it can be destroyed so when I
ask our Muslim friends how can the Quran
be destroyed when the Quran is Allah's
Eternal speech their answer should be
listen David as Muslims we're not saying
that when someone destroys a Quran
Allah's Eternal speech is destroyed no
when someone destroys a Quran the paper
and glue and ink that make up the
physical nature of the Quran are
destroyed but the Eternal nature of the
Quran remains
unchanged interesting response that I
had to give you to clear up your
confusion let me see if I
understand the Eternal speech of Allah
which is uncreated and indestructible
can enter our physical world as a
physical Quran which is created and can
be destroyed if this Quran Quan is
destroyed Muslims won't say that Allah's
Eternal speech is destroyed they'll
simply say that the Quran has two
Natures an eternal nature and a physical
nature and that it's the physical nature
that can be destroyed by ripping it up
or burning it Etc wonderful I'm happy we
finally understand the Dual nature of
the
Quran but now I'm confused again because
according to Islam something that's
Eternal and indestructible can indeed
take on a physical nature that's not
Eternal and that can be destroyed and
yet our Muslim friends tell us that it's
impossible for something that's Eternal
and indestructible to take on a physical
nature that's not Eternal and that can
be
destroyed are they still making up rules
as they go along without bothering to
consider how their madeup rules demolish
their own
theology Christians claim that the
Divine son the Eternal Word of God
became flesh and dwelt Among Us that
that he entered into creation as Jesus
of Nazareth and that because he had
taken on human flesh which was created
and perishable he was capable of dying
even though apart from taking on human
flesh he couldn't
die what rule makes Christian theology
absurd here that wouldn't also make
Islamic theology
absurd but the hypocrisy becomes even
more glaring when we realize that
according to Muhammad himself the Quran
Allah's Eternal speech Allah's Eternal
Word appears as a man Muhammad said in
Sun IB ma
3781 the Quran will come on the day of
Resurrection like a Pale Man and will
say I am the one that kept you awake at
night and made you thirsty during the
day in the Muslim sources the Quran
appears as a man a white man the Quran
speaks the Quran remembers the Quran
intercedes the Quran is there I say it
personal even better it's actually
multi-personality Among Us is absurd
while the word became paper and glue and
ink and sat on David Wood's bookshelf
makes perfect
sense until I get a good response here
which I won't I can only conclude that
Christians and Muslims have to agree
that something Eternal and
indestructible can enter creation and
take on a physical nature that's
temporal and capable of being destroyed
but if we have to agree on this point
why are Muslims so confused used by the
Christian claim that Jesus is God and
that Jesus entered into creation and
died on the cross the real confusion on
this issue doesn't come from Christian
theology it comes from Islamic theology
Muslims simply have no concept of a God
who would do something like that for
human beings in Islam it makes no sense
for Allah to enter his creation to die
for sins because Allah's Justice and
love and mercy are all limited and in
imperfect for instance what does the
Quran say about Allah's love Allah does
not love those who exceed the limits
Surah 2 verse 190 Allah does not love
any ungrateful sinner Surah 2 verse
276 Allah does not love the unbelievers
Surah
3:32 Allah does not love the unjust
3:57 Allah does not love him who is
proud boastful Surah 4:36 Allah does not
love the extravagant Surah
7:31 Allah does not love the treacherous
Surah 8:58 Allah does not love the
Mischief Makers Surah 28: 77 Allah does
not love any arrogant boaster Surah 57:
23 the god of Muhammad only loves those
who love him first Allah has no love for
rebellious sinners or unbelievers in
Islam your relationship to Allah is a
slave to master relationship Surah 19
verse 93 there is none in the heavens
and the Earth but comes unto the most
beneficent Allah as a
slave a master doesn't automatically
love his slave a master may eventually
come to love a slave who serves him well
for many years but what slave master is
ever going to lay down his life for his
slaves so would a cosmic slave master
who doesn't love Sinners or unbelievers
enter into the world to die for
rebellious slaves and unbelievers who
are sinning against him of course not
the god of the Quran wouldn't do that
because he just doesn't care about
people that much this is the real reason
Muslims can't grasp the Incarnation and
sacrificial death of Jesus I should also
point out that Allah's Justice is
limited and FL according to Islam if
Allah wants to forgive you he can just
sweep your sins under the rug pretend
they never
happened that may be merciful but it's
not just Islam teaches that at the end
of time there will be unpunished sin
that means that Allah's Justice isn't
perfect he's going to let some sin
slide how does this compare with the god
of the Bible Well the god of the Bible
is perfect in his attributes God's love
and mercy are perfect God calls us his
children again a slave master doesn't
automatically love his slave but a
father does automatically love his child
God loves Sinners so much that he
entered into Creation in order to pay
the price for our sins Romans 56 to8
says you see at just the right time when
we were still powerless Christ died for
the
ungodly very rarely will anyone die for
a righteous person though for a good
person someone might possibly dare to
die but God demonstrates his own love
for us in this while we were still
sinners Christ died for
us notice also that all sin is
eventually punished in Christianity
either you pay for your own sins or
you're forgiven in which case Jesus
himself takes the penalty since the god
of the Bible punishes all sins his his
Justice is perfect now I know that this
is difficult for our Muslim friends to
grasp they can't comprehend a God who
would love people so much that he would
lay aside his glory enter into his
creation and pay the price for our sins
but let me ask you this my Muslim friend
suppose you were king of the world
dressed in Royal
robes one day you're riding around on
your favorite horse when you look over
and see your child drowning in a pool of
mud would you look at your child
drowning and say I wish I could help but
I'm just too glorious and Majestic for
that or would you toss your robes aside
and dive right into that mud to save the
child you love would it matter to you
that you're king of the world no all
that would matter is your
child if that's how great you your love
is how much greater do you think God's
love
is enough to enter creation and die for
us that's the god that Jesus proclaims
and that you reject because you prefer
the cosmic slave master who just doesn't
care about you that
much Muslims bring up these objections
to show Christians that there's
something wrong with our view of God but
as soon as we dig a Little Deeper we
find that the Muslim view insults and
degrades God by limiting his attributes
while the Christian view honors God by
displaying his
Perfection God can be defined as the
greatest possible being or as a
maximally perfect being so if I can
think of a being greater than your God
you're not really worshiping
God guess what I can easily think of a
being greater than the god of the Quran
in fact in at least one way I'm greater
than the god of of the Quran I love
unbelievers Allah doesn't so my love is
greater than
Allah's of course my love is nothing
compared to the love of the god of the
Bible who demonstrated his love for us
and confirmed his message by Jesus
resurrection from the
dead and now he commands you to repent
and believe the
gospel what's the final objection when I
say beli the gospel but David the gospel
was
corrupted not according to the
Quran one of the great ironies in all of
this is that the defective inferior god
of the Quran affirms the inspiration
preservation and authority of the Gospel
which portrays God as perfect in love
and mercy and Justice our Muslim friends
don't know this because they don't read
the Quran for themselves eles instead
they listen to their dises who can't
stop making things
up to all my Muslim friends who are
watching do yourself a huge favor and
watch my video what the Quran really
says about the gospel where I go through
every single verse in the Quran that
even mentions the
gospel watch the video and then explain
to me why you claim that the gospel has
been corrupted when your God and your
profit say the exact
[Music]
opposite